dans le 7 8 avec changement de visage en
plateau et notamment Régine rage qui
nous a rejoint bonsoir Régine de la
rédaction de TV 78 alors comme chaque
semaine vous nous présentez une école
une formation du territoire c'est dans
le cadre de cette période de formulation
des vœux sur parcoursup et aujourd'hui
c'est au tour de l'IUT de Rambouillet en
tout cas l'une des formations proposées
à l'IUT de Rambouillet
qui tournait vers les métiers du
marketing et de la communication et un
plateau avec nous Serino ouaglani et
maysane Haïti bonsoir alors vous êtes
étudiante à l'IUT de Rambouillet et vous
avez récemment participé au concours
vidéo pour justement présenter votre
formation et pour aider les jeunes à
s'orienter dans leur parcours scolaire
je vous propose de regarder un extrait
toute la semaine mais tu peux aller en
alternance tu fais trois jours en
entreprise et deux jours à l'école
franchement je trouve que l'idée qu'elle
m'a donné des filles c'est une très très
bonne idée le marketing digital c'est
une grande opportunité de nos jours et
surtout qu'on vient de parcours
ou encore bac pro c'est bon allez on se
motive
alors dans cette vidéo vous avez parlé
de la formation bttc mais c'est quoi au
juste c'est une formation
pluridisciplinaire qui organisée autour
du marketing de la vente et de la
communication à la suite de ça vous
pouvez d'ailleurs occuper des postes
comme community manager donc vous
connaît très bien sur les réseaux
sociaux mais aussi Trafic Manager donc
c'est la personne qui gère la mise en
ligne des campagnes publicitaires et
alors du coup ce cursus il peut se faire
en initial et en alternance vous avez
quatre choix de parcours vous avez la
stratégie de marque événementiel le
business international le business
développement relation client et
marketing digital entrepreneuriat et E
business
de commercialisation c'est bien ça tu as
beaucoup de d'acronymes on a parlé d'IUT
de but d'ailleurs il y a une époque pas
si pas si lointaine on disait dut c'est
quoi la différence c'est la même chose
le DUT c'est plus totalement la même
chose justement il y a une réforme qui
arrive donc à partir de septembre
prochain donc actuellement il y a
toujours les DUT et on peut également
faire une licence professionnelle donc
que ça fait trois ans au total mais les
députés se faisaient sur deux ans et le
buttc se fera sur trois ans donc c'est
le Bachelor universitaire de technologie
mais comment fait-on pour intégrer cette
formation alors cette formation elle est
accessible via parcoursup il faut avoir
bien évidemment un bon dossier il faut
faire un CV et une lettre de motivation
ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est qu'il
est on peut être issu en fait d'un bac
général technologique ou professionnel
alors Régine parler de ce concours
auquel vous avez participé pour
présenter votre formation pourquoi ça
vous tenait à coeur d'y participer
pourquoi le présenter de cette manière
là c'est assez original quand même de
présenter cette formation de cette
manière en vidéo en fait nous avons
voulu toucher le plus de jeunes on
savait que des de nombreux jeunes
regardez justement la téléréalité et
qu'avec l'humour forcément ça a l'air
intéressé beaucoup de jeunes on les
touche plus facilement avec ce type de
contenu
on a fait on a participé à ce concours
dans le cadre de notre formation au
préalable on a eu plusieurs cours
théoriques comment écrire un script les
différentes caméras pour les différentes
situations et on a pu mettre tout ça en
pratique justement en participant au
concours donc ça a été une belle
expérience qu'on a pu qu'on a pu
partager tous ensemble
pour mener à cette vidéo exactement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter un
peu votre parcours on peut commencer par
vous mais il San alors moi après
l'obtention de mon baccalauréat
scientifique que j'ai eu avec mention
assez bien
j'étais assez perdue dans mes études
donc je savais pas
quel quel parcours j'allais entamer je
pense beaucoup de jeunes peuvent
se retrouver dans mon discours
j'ai choisi d'intégrer un BTS Gestion
des petites maïses ce qui m'a permis de
d'avoir une vision globale de tous les
corps métiers qu'on peut de tous les
corps de métiers qu'on peut retrouver
dans une entreprise donc que ça soit
ressources humaines la communication la
relation client fournisseur le marketing
du Market non justement je n'avais pas
vu marketing et justement j'ai pu
visualiser l'impact du digital et j'ai
voulu justement apprendre toutes les
techniques de marketing mais
spécifiquement dans le monde du digital
suite au covid-19 j'ai pu
réaliser que
sans digital va
on peut pas s'exonérer difficile
exactement
et pour vous votre parcours pour moi
alors j'ai fait un bac professionnel
vente
il faut savoir que c'est possible de
continuer de poursucer ses études après
un bac pro même si ça reste quand même
compliqué ensuite j'ai poursuivi avec un
BTS mdrc Négociation digitalisation de
la relation client donc il y avait déjà
de la digitalisation
on apprenait à utiliser WordPress à
animer des réseaux sociaux etc donc j'ai
pris la poursuite dite logique j'ai
poursuit j'ai poursuivi en licence
professionnelle e-commerce et marketing
numérique donc voilà différents parcours
qui permettent aussi de pouvoir arriver
à cette formation
c'est des matières qu'on va retrouver
exactement dans le but TC l'an prochain
et justement quelles sont les matières
que vous apprenez aujourd'hui
alors c'est une formation
pluridisciplinaire donc c'est vraiment
très vaste et personnellement c'est ce
que j'aime dans cette formation c'est
que on va découvrir plein de choses et
on y voit principalement donc c'est
centré sur digital donc comment créer un
site internet comment le développer on a
pu voir du codage html et c'est
comment l'animer donc et toutes les
techniques de marketing qu'on va pouvoir
mettre en place au sein du site internet
exactement compléter on a aussi pu faire
du montage vidéo l'infographie de la
conduite de projets aussi et aussi on
nous sensibilise aux droits du numérique
tout ce qui est rgpd propriété
intellectuelle notamment
brevet des dessins et modèles etc donc
on est vraiment sensibilité
à tous les domaines qui touchent le
numérique oui c'est très actuel
exactement
au justement quel est votre projet
derrière quel métier vous souhaiteriez
exercer toutes les deux pour ma part
j'ai pour objectif d'intégrer
l'iaefel pour pour le marketing pour un
Master Marketing Digital c'est quoi
pardon c'est pour eux poursuivre la
formation c'est un institut de formation
exactement et pour vous et moi alors
j'aimerais intégrer l'université de
Paris Nanterre pour le Master
information et communication parcours
flux de l'information et dossiers et
documents électroniques et pourquoi pas
plus tard devenir maître de conférences
il nous reste du temps juste pour une
question
de votre formation si vous deviez la
vendre comme vous l'avez fait dans la
vidéo mais si vous deviez la vendre à
noter les spectateurs c'est quoi le
point fort
personnellement je trouve beaucoup de
points forts mais pour moi le plus
impactant c'est le corps professionnel
on a eu la chance d'avoir des
professeurs qui des intervenants qui ont
créé leur propre entreprise
récemment une professeure qui a créé son
entreprise autour du digital pour pour
un cours sur le marketing plus
précisément sur les sur le mobile donc
c'est vraiment enrichissant d'une part
ils peuvent nous transmettre tout leur
savoir-faire et d'autre part on a des
situations concrètes c'est pas seulement
un cours enfin si c'est un court
théorique mais on retrouve beaucoup de
situations dans lequel on plonge et on
les captivé par le cours
si je puis si je peux ajouter alors en
fait on est totalement immergé dans le
monde du digital au sein de cette
formation
notamment notre directrice de formation
nous fait faire plusieurs sorties
pédagogiques donc on va aller au salon
du marketing et on va visiter un
incubateur justement à Roubaix je crois
et découvrir une plateforme logistique
et bien merci d'avoir fait découvrir
cette formation but technique de
commercialisation merci à Céline merci
mais ça d'être venu en parlant rappelle
que vous êtes étudiante à l'IUT de
Rambouillet qui est rattaché à
l'Université Versailles